I'm drawn to Fascinating People on some
sort of Journey overcoming some sort of
obstacle I mean that's all my docs have
had some element of that whether it's
you know cartels in Mexico Isis in Syria
end of the war in Afghanistan whatever
it is I'm drawn to people who are trying
to overcome something that is often
insurmountable you know my goal is to
get as as deep and intimate to their
souls to their beings to who they were
as as possible and to be able to be with
artists who are surviving as they say in
the movie with through their art during
this incredibly difficult moment of
their life was an unbelievable thing to
witness